So we talked about security planing sort
of, consist of many different parts,
the last one was we
talked about controls.
Next, we talk what we call
a security policy that you have.
Who talking daily about
enterprise security policy.
You could have policies at national
level or something like that.
Federal government may have one
across its different agencies, and
each agency may have its own and things
like that, but if you think about this
in the context of an enterprise,
security planning requires that you have
some sort of a security policy,
what exactly is a security policy.
A security policy really sort
of at the high level articulate,
what are the security objectives are?
What is that want to?
What goals do we have?
We want to maintain confidentiality.
We want to make sure that
sensitive is not disclosed
to parties not authorized to see it.
We want our systems to be available.
We don't want our data to be corrupted.
We don't want sensitive
data to get into the hands.
We want to be legally compliant or
whatever.
Cause you can think of all the kind of
security objectives somebody might have.
Which actually motivate
what a policy is.
So often this high level articulation
requires it would include
some sort of a legal, business and
regulatory rationale for
why the policy has what it does.
While legal and regulatory you
don't really have lot of choice.
Business, reasons tell you why it's good
for the enterprise or for the company.
And what's good for the company,
of course, is good for its employees.
So that's the articulation of
the outlined reasons why we want to
have the kind of policy that we do.
So the policy is really what you
should do and what should not be done.
So we talked about passwords,
for example.
What kind of password you should choose,
what the size and
length of your password,
things like that.
We may have web and
email policy, for example,
can use surf the web
while you're at work.
The policy actually might say, if
something were to go wrong there is some
security event that occurs, what sort of
response is that we're going to have.
Do you need,
if your machine gets compromised.
Do you had informed somebody for
example.
The security policy or
the dos and don'ts, and
we saw some examples of those, of course
they may have to do with prevention, so
bad things don't happen.
They may have to do with detection, so
compromise how you find out that there
was a breach may have to do with how
we respond to that sort of a thing and
how remediation occurs, and of course
it must address the concerns and
impact and
that could any of these things have.
So rationale, articulation of why things
need to be the way the policy says
they should be and if it doesn't sort
of address the concerns and needs and
impact it may have on users of course
the policy may not be well accepted.